starting at home oh mama travelled
uphill to the gift store for 45 minutes
at just eight miles per hour
she then traveled back home along the
same path
downhill at a speed of 24 miles per hour
what is her average speed for the entire
trip from home to the gift store and
back so we're trying to figure out her
total her average speed for the entire
trip that's going to be equal to the
total distance the total distance that
she traveled over the total time over
the total time total time well what's
the total distance going to be well the
total distance is going to be the
distance to the gift store and then the
distance back from the gift store which
are the same distances so it's really
you could say 2 times the distance to
the gift store so 2 times the distance
distance to the gift store to the gift
store and then what is going to be her
total time well it's time to the gift
store so it's time time to gift store
and then plus the time coming back time
coming coming back from the gift store
now we know that the distance to the
gift store in the distance back from the
gift store is the same so that's why I
just said that the total distance is
just going to be 2 times the distance to
the gift store we don't know in fact we
know we're going to have different times
in terms of times to the gift store and
times coming back how do I know that
well she went at different speeds so
it's going to take her it's going to
take her actually she went she went
there much slower than she came back so
it would take her longer to get there
than it took her to get back so let's
see which of these we can actually we
already know so how do we figure out the
distance to the gift store no point here
do they say hey the gift store is this
far away but they do tell us this first
sentence right over here
oh mama travelled uphill to the gift
store for 45 minutes at just 8 miles at
just 8 miles per hour so we're given a
time and we are given a
and we're given a speed we should be
able to figure out a distance so let's
just do a little bit of a side here we
should be able to figure out the
distance to the distance let me write it
this way distance to the store distance
to store will be equal to and we got to
make sure we have our units right here
they gave it in minutes here they have
eight miles per hour so let's convert
this let's convert this into hours so 45
minutes in hours so it's 45 minutes out
of 60 minutes per hour so that's going
to give us 45 sixtieths divide both by
15 that's the same thing as 3/4 so it's
going to be 3/4 hours 3/4 hours is the
time times an average speed of 8 miles
per hour times 8 miles per hour so what
is the distance to the store
well 3/4 times 8 or you could view it as
3/4 times 8 times 1 is going to be
what's going to be 24 over 4 let me just
write that that's going to be 24 over 4
which is equal to to get 24 over 4 which
is equal to 6 and units wise we're just
left with miles
so the distance to the toilet store is 6
miles 2 times the distance to the gift
store well this whole thing is going to
be 12 miles 12 miles is the total
distance she traveled now what is the
time to the gift store where they
already told that to us they already
told us that it's fort it's 45 minutes
now I want to put everything in hours
I'm assuming that we they want our
average speed an hour so I'm going to
put everything in hours so the time to
the gift store was 3/4 of an hour 3/4
hours and what's the time coming back
from the gift store well we know her
speed we know her speed coming back we
already know the distance from the gift
store it's the same as the distance to
the gift store so we can figure we can
take this distance we can take 6 miles
that's the distance to the gift store
six miles divided by her speed coming
back which is 24 miles per hour so
divided by 24 miles per hour gives us
let's see we're going to have six over
24 is the same thing as 1/4 it's going
to be 1/4 and then miles divided by
miles per hour is the same thing as
miles times hours per mile the miles
cancel out and you'll have 1/4 of an
hour so it takes for 1/4 of an hour to
get back and that's that fits our
intuition actually write that in same
green color since I'm writing all the
times and colors in green color so 1/4
of an hour so she went there going to
the gift store was slow took her 3/4 of
an hour coming back only took her 1/4 of
an hour 1/4 of an hour so now we're
ready to calculate her average speed for
the entire trip her average speed for
the entire trip is going to be equal to
the total distance which is 12 miles 12
miles divided by her total time 3/4
hours plus 1/4 hour is exactly one hour
so her average speed is 12 over 1 which
is just 12 miles per hour her average
speed is just 12 miles per hour
and you might have been tempted to say
anyway why don't I just average 24 and 8
but that wouldn't have been right
because she's traveling those for
different amounts of time so what you
really have to do is just think in terms
of go back to your basics total distance
total time figure out the total distance
this first sentence right over here
gives us half of the total distance the
time to the store we just doubled that
to get the time back and then our total
time we can figure out they tell us the
time to the store and then we can figure
out the distance from the store and
using that and the velocity speed to
figure out her time back and then we get
total tot distance divided by total time
12 miles per hour